60 years ago today communist east
germany began the construction of the
berlin wall overnight families and
friends were separated and the lives and
destinies of countless people were
changed forever by the time it fell in
1989 more than 100 people had been
killed trying to get over or under the
wall to freedom in the west east
germany's leaders said it was an
anti-fascist barrier but the wall became
a symbol of repression preventing east
germans from leaving
from the very beginning many of them
tried to do just that dw's tessa valta
spoke to an eyewitness of one of the
first and most famous examples of
jumping the wall
was still a young man when he witnessed
this historic moment
the east german border policeman conrad
schumann jumped over the border fence
between east and west berlin
today the wall is gone here only iron
bars mark the former border but the 82
year old still remembers it clearly yes
[Music]
this is exactly where i was standing a
few people were in front of me
and we just saw him as he was jumping
over the fence
we all cheered and we welcomed him with
open arms
it was right here
[Music]
in the years before more and more people
had fled from east to west berlin
escaping the communist dictatorship
in 1961
east germany deployed border guards to
stop the population drain one of them
was conrad schumann
but instead of defending communism he
chose to jump to the democratic west
it took a lot of courage to dare jumping
over that fence especially as a border
guard that was really great if i had
been on duty with all the other guards
around i don't think i would have had
the courage i mean they could have shot
[Music]
what began with a bit of barbed wire
soon became a solid concrete structure
the berlin wall
it divided the city for 28 years
it tore families and friendships apart
[Music]
now 60 years after the war was built ben
bruder has a clear message for the
younger generations who never
experienced it
we need to fight to make sure that a war
is never again built here in germany let
alone a national border
and we should all make sure that there
is never another war in germany
germany's and berlin's reunification is
still today one of the greatest
occasions in his country's history
our chief political correspondent
melinda crane is at the berlin wall
memorial for us good morning melinda how
is this day being commemorated
that message that we just heard at the
end of the report a message of how
important it is to remember and how
important it is that walls never again
uh be built that's exactly the message
we're hearing right here right now at a
commemoration
ceremony i'm standing at the bernauer
straza wall memorial this is the place
where conrad schumann jumped the wall as
it was being built and it's also a place
where the east german communist regime
dynamited a church to create a
defensible zone along the wall you can
see it behind me
the so-called death strip president
frank walter steinmeier is speaking
right now we will also hear from
berlin's lord mayor michelle miller with
similar messages uh calling for
remembrance and the need to defend and
be committed to freedom and to
historical witnesses who saw the events
here 60 years ago we'll also be speaking
well
germany is holding elections next month
30 years after reunification how are
german politics still shaped by that
history itself
many people
say that in fact we have two electorates
in germany one in the east and one in
the west the far-right afd party with
its populist anti-immigrant messages
regularly wins a significantly larger
share of the vote in the eastern states
uh up
20
and more and is the second strongest
political party in many of those states
the fact is that has more to do with
what happened after the fall of the wall
than before many east germans who fought
for freedoms in 1989 had the feeling
that afterward they became second-class
citizens they saw companies shut down
many young people move away to better
jobs in the west uh and wages today are
still lower in the east than the than
the west unemployment is higher in many
parts of the east for all those reasons
many east germans are receptive to the
identity politics of the afd far-right
party
and melinda if we talk about the wall
itself a lot of people thought think of
it as having been built suddenly but
that wasn't the case and historians are
finding out more about that what can you
tell us
no in fact on june 15th 1961
the head of the east german communist
party central committee while walter
ulbricht told the press no one has the
intention of building a wall what we
know now is that as early as 1953 he had
appealed to russian leader nikita
khrushchev to close the border between
east berlin and west berlin and that the
east german regime had very seriously
considered putting up a barrier as early
as 1958 in order to stop a massive
exodus of east germans to the west
including people of working age who were
badly needed another fact that has
emerged fairly recently the east german
regime was prepared for massive protests
on that august 13 60 years ago they took
the necessary precautions and then in
fact the eastern party of the city was
relatively quiet and it seems that many
east berliners
accepted or perhaps even approved of the
construction of the wall thinking it was
the only way to preserve the economic
viability of a communist dream that many
of them still believed in and the fact
is some were also resentful of east
berliners who had been computing to the
west enjoying privileges there higher
salaries consumer goods and of course
the construction of the wall did put an
end to that
our chief political correspondent
melinda green craned for us at the
berlin wall memorial today thank you